if you thought your reserved D box seats
to the 3d IMAX showing of star wars the
force awakens
cost an arm and a leg huh you ain't seen
nothing yet
hello Internet
welcome to film theory where today hold
on to your fitted Jedi leggings aka your
jeggings ah duh because we're talking
about the economics of building the
Death Star and before you wander away
thinking that this is just gonna be a
bunch of math for the next 15 minutes
well there's gonna be some math but that
math will totally be worth it because by
the end of the episode you're gonna
learn that there's a force in the galaxy
far more dangerous than the dark side
and that forces market force and in the
context of that force the Jedi are far
more destructive than the Sith ever
release here viously get ready to never
look at this scene the same way again it
seems like the logical place to start is
to figure out how much the Death Star
actually costs to make I mean this is
one massive ship right so before we go
making any big revelations about Star
Wars we have to get down to nuts and
bolts literally according to Wikipedia
the whole of the Death Star is made out
of substance known as quod an iam steel
according to the information we have all
the outside parts of the Death Star are
made from this steel alloy which is
supposed to be a super strong Armour and
while it may be tough it's not like it's
impenetrable or anything since all the
generations of TIE fighters we see in
the original trilogy
we're also made out of this alloy we
also see that it can be blown up pretty
much like any other regular ship so it's
a special steel but since there's not a
lot of information on it and it looks
and functions a lot like normal metal in
our calculations we're going to just
treat it like a regular steel owl
fortunately for us some economic
students and fellow Star Wars Ian's at
Lehigh University in Pennsylvania
actually calculated how much steel it
takes to build the Death Star
as with any fictional device that you're
trying to bring into the real world
you're gonna face some limitations and
as a result make some assumptions for
them they compared the Death Star to
what would basically be a battleship but
instead of floating on water it floats
into space this is pretty rational since
they both need to be protected from all
kinds of weaponry both have to be
airtight
and they're both weapon platforms that
need to be totally self-contained either
in the vacuum of space or in the middle
of the ocean next they took the
dimension
the Deathstar which according to the
Star Wars encyclopedia and the online
wiki's is a hundred and forty kilometers
in diameter or about 87 miles across
just to give you some context that's
125th the size of the moon next they
scaled everything up from a modern
warship to the size of the Death Star
and found that you would need 1.0 8
times 10 to the 15th tons of steel to
construct as in 1.0 8 x 1 0 0 0 0 0 0 0
0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 and sometimes this
happens with our theories right where
the numbers just get so ridiculously big
for us to even know what they mean so
let's put this in perspective comparing
that number to the steel on earth it
actually doesn't look that crazy based
on the amount of iron in the planet
earth iron alloy makes steel by the way
just so you know you could actually
produce 2 million death star shells out
of it granted the earth would literally
be mined dry completely gone and the
core would be gutted but it seems like
producing just one measly Death Star
wouldn't be such a big deal that is
until you look at how long it actually
takes to turn the raw iron into steel
at the current rate earth produces steel
it would take our planet more than
800,000 years just to get enough for the
Death Star that's not even counting all
the other components and parts that you
need for such a massive Space Station
how long does it take to produce enough
steel to build your everyday warship for
the ocean less than an hour
ok so this is gonna be a big project but
it doesn't stop there knowing how much
steel it takes is all well and good but
you can't just mine a gajillion tons of
Steel for free that much steel is gonna
need some serious cash
here's where the numbers get really
crazy our friends at lehigh kept
researching the stats of the Death Star
and we're able to calculate that at the
price of steel in 2012 one point zero
eight times 10 to the 15th tons of steel
would cost you about eight hundred and
fifty-two quadrillion dollar compare
that to the gross world product for 2014
that's how much money was produced by
the entire world economy of every
country in a year the gross world
product in 2014 was 77 trillion
sixty-eight billion seven hundred
sixty-eight million dollars that means
the price for just the steel on the
Death Star would be almost 11 thousand
times all the money made in the world in
a single year and I want to make sure
that we're really clear here that this
isn't just some huge number I'm waving
out in front of you this cost of the
Death Star has actually been verified in
writing by our own US government
good job guys these are the sorts of
things that you should be wasting your
time on a couple years ago a petition
for the US government circulated to
build a real Death Star under the
assumption that it would help us bolster
our national defense and obviously fend
off the Rebel Alliance sorry I just love
that this was a real thing that happened
it got so many signatures that the White
House officially responded to it with a
huge letter even though they ultimately
declined the request to build a gigantic
Death Ray in space they did use data to
back up their decision they also pointed
out that blowing up planets isn't a good
idea but offered an alternative solution
if the government wasn't gonna fund it
you could always ask for private funding
through NASA's Commercial Crew and cargo
program office otherwise known as c-3po
I kid you not the world is run by a
bunch of nerds it is glorious
so yes confirmed by the US government
this is seriously what it would cost to
build a Death Star and we're just
talking about the basic model remember
you also need a lot more than steel to
keep this thing going
you need tons of quarters for cruise you
need all the internal life-support
systems onboard computers laser engines
huge plasma containment cells the steel
is just the beginning again making the
best comparison we can between the Death
Star and a regular warship we can make a
rough calculation for how much the rest
of the components would cost our friends
over at Lehigh use the USS Gerald Ford
which costs seventeen point five billion
dollars including our DS if we
extrapolate that out to the Death Star
the total cost for the first Death Star
would be as high as 193 quintillion
dollars so that's how much the Death
Star would cost in our earth dollars
today and that seems like a lot right
and it is for a single planet remember
we're only looking at it from Earth's
respective the Deathstar was built using
an entire galaxies worth of resources
where there are thousands of inhabited
planets and trillions of people cores
and alone has over one trillion
inhabitants when you look at it that way
and also that it took about 20 years to
build it's actually not that bad but
while the cost of building the Death
Star isn't that big of a deal in the
grand scheme of the galaxy the cost of
destroying the Death Star is something
else entirely
when the first Death Star was being
built almost everyone in the galaxy was
pretty much just going about their own
business
like we said building the space station
doesn't really affect them all that much
it's a government project just like
building a bridge but when good old Luke
Skywalker comes along and uses the force
that's when the real problems for the
galaxy start I'm not talking about
planets blowing up although yeah sorry
about that older
I'm talking about everyone's worst
nightmare a recession before you laugh
this off a recession across an entire
galaxy is no cakewalk the biggest issue
here is that terrorist attacks hurt the
economy and bad and destroying the Death
Star would be labeled as the largest
ever act of galactic terrorism oh yeah
it's easy to forget amidst the cool
laser swords and fun space battles that
the rebels are exactly that rebels sure
the government may be controlled by an
evil Sith Lord but it's a stable system
and even then the majority of the
populace don't even realize that Vader
and Palpatine are all that bad to them
Luke Han Leia and all the rest are
extremists trying to overthrow the
government and just successfully blew up
the largest military base in history and
that is good compare the Death Star
attack to something we know here the
9/11 attacks following 9/11 two of the
world's most important stock indexes the
Dow Jones in the S&P 500 dropped
overnight by 14 percent and 12 percent
respectively and then stayed there no
you don't have to know what those are
it's a topic for another day what you do
need to know is that sudden double-digit
drops like this result in economic
crashes as consumers become nervous and
spend less money which in turn results
in less income for companies companies
are then forced to make layoffs and the
resulting higher unemployment means even
less spending lower productivity for
everyone companies and individuals alike
the economy struggles to recover
destroying the Death Star would cause
this kind of collapse except instead of
being on a national scale this would
literally ripple across thousands of
other planets the other big problem in
the destruction of the Death Star is the
murder of major political and military
figures this might seem like a good
thing because yeah we got the bad guys
especially with the second Death Star
you're talking about killing Emperor
Palpatine but history shows that killing
off major world leaders doesn't exactly
stimulate the economy this is comparable
to April 23rd 2013 when The Associated
Press made a mistake of tweeting that
the White House had been hit by a
terrorist attack and that President
Obama has been injured of course the
tweet was wrong but in the four minutes
it took before they got it retracted the
stock market dropped by one
in four minutes there's no question that
the immediate impact of Luke destroying
the Death Star would be to send the
Galactic economy reeling the Galactic
Trade Federation would take a huge hit
slowing down all the major galactic
trade routes and causing serious
resource or without brought resource
shortages and causing serious resource
shortages I cannot say that I cannot say
that for that that is really hard to say
resource shortages causing serious
resource shortages as remote planets see
their imports take a big hit high I did
it and things only get worse from there
remember the rebels destroy two Death
Star's and when Palpatine dies in Death
Star to his absence would lead to a
temporary collapse of the entire
political system without any sort of
central structure or leader this
collapse would also mean that the Empire
would have defaulted on all of its debt
to the planets that might not seem like
a big deal but it means that basically
the Empire can't pay anyone back for
anything including the Death Star's all
those resources and money used to make
this thing to use a phrase from South
Park and it's gone these are the most
expensive military projects in history
not to mention the Empire has been
financing a war against the rebels for
years one might call it a war on terror
and now none of it can be paid for all
the industries related to military and
arms manufacturing would collapse and
many other industries would follow suit
as a result so what does all this mean
well first of all it means that
destroying the Death Star is a lot more
complicated than the good guys won in
fact it's pretty reasonable to think
that destroying the Death Star and
Emperor Palpatine wouldn't lead back to
a prosperous democratic republic where
everyone gets flowers and medals it
would actually lead to a deep recession
and a massive power grab for lots of
individual factions rushed to try to
fill the void left by the Emperor and
take control of the galaxy meanwhile
door Denari citizens the galaxy would
suffer for years to come cut off from
all supplies and resources from other
planets stuffing their credits into
their mattresses and waiting out the
recession caused by the Jedi destroying
the Death Star would actually have the
exact opposite effect that Luke and the
Jedi think it will Economist's they are
not
and that's the point here ultimately
there's a big difference between a
political revolution and a violent
revolution we think of Emperor Palpatine
as being this really destructive guy but
his revolution from Old Republic to
Empire was much smoother and safer
economically than the rebels hostile
takeover sure Palpatine used
manipulation and coercion to get power
and eventually bumped off a few Jedi but
he pretty much left the Galactic
population alone in the process everyone
else was able to live their lives
without too much problem again
sorry Alderaan bummer for you the armed
and violent coup that the Rebel Alliance
performs is much more sudden and
ultimately more disruptive to more
people
really if the Rebel Alliance truly
wanted to bring peace to the galaxy a
better way of life for everyone to
reform their Republic they will have
needed to take a page from the dark side
and work a little magic behind the
scenes rather than destroying not just
the Death Star but the whole galaxy's
way of life so what the force awakens
takes place 30 years after the original
trilogy
oh no everyone there should be an utter
economic devastation that's the true
story of the force awakens but hey
that's just a theory a film theory and
cut and if you can't get enough Star
Wars find out even more hidden truths
about the dark side and light side of
the force by clicking here to watch my
friends over at Screen Rant
they just did a theory exploring how
George Lucas made the force to parallel
the eastern yin and yang symbol finding
clues as to how the new trilogy story
will unfold based on this balance of
dark and light it's a really cool
analysis kinda wish I'd thought of it
myself actually or if your kind of Star
Wars doubt for the time being click here
to learn how to do the Kamehameha wave
from Dragonball surprisingly there is a
real-world explanation for what you're
seeing here still no explanation though
for how napped Yamcha is that guy man
useless just
useless and finally make sure that you
subscribe because we have theories on
Batman Superman and Full Metal Alchemist
on the way